what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the single biggest secret
and the greatest unsolved mystery in the
demon slayer story the one secret that
is sure to become more and more
important as the story goes on I am
referring to the legendary breath of the
Sun and it's dark counterpart the breath
of the moon and how these mysterious
breath styles continue to play a crucial
role in the demon slayers story in this
video I will explain everything that we
know so far about the breath of the Sun
and the breath of the moon and why these
breathing styles have become so
important for the overall story I hope
that having all of this information
right here in one place will be useful
to you and if you do find these types of
videos useful you can leave a like to
let me know if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications and finally
please be advised that this video will
contain manga spoilers I will be relying
on all the information that we have so
far up to this point in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in order to properly discuss
the legendary breath of the Sun we first
need to talk about the dance of the
fire-god the dance of the fire-god is a
mysterious fire-based breath style known
and taught only by the Commodore family
and it has been passed on from father to
son within the Commodore family for
hundreds of years the breath of flames
user Shin judo Arango KU believes that
dance of the fire-god is actually the
original breath style the godly breath
that was the first ever created and the
one from which every other breath is
derived the name of this godly breath
style is the breath of the Sun at first
Tangier I didn't really know anything
about the breath of the Sun and he
assured Sheen to Durango ku that he is
not some legendary chosen warrior the
only reason why he can use the breath of
the fire God is because his father
performed it as a ritual ceremony once a
year but Shinju roaring Goku insists
that the dance of the fire God is the
breath of the Sun and according to Rango
ku all the other breath styles are just
inferior copies to the breathless
on this means that the breath of the Sun
and the dance of the fire-god if the two
are the same thing is by its very nature
more powerful than any other breath
style this is important and I will
return to this point in a little bit
ever since we first learned about the
breath of the Sun there have been some
pretty clear clues in the story that
tangi rose family has a direct
connection to the original breath of the
Sun user in chapter 99 of the manga we
finally get direct confirmation about
the connection between an ancestor of
Tangier oh by the name of Sumiyoshi and
the breath of the Sun user whose real
name turns out to be URI Chi
Sookie Cooney tan Jiro has a dream
although it seems to actually be a
memory that he inherited from his
ancestor Sumiyoshi
in that memory he sees a scene from 400
years ago when his ancestor who was a
humble coal burner was hosting the
breath of the Sun user at his home for
some reason the breath of the Sun user
was staying with Sumiyoshi and at one
point the breath of the Sun user says
that he couldn't achieve what he was
supposed to achieve in life and that he
couldn't protect a single thing that was
important to him he then calls himself a
man of no worth and tangelos ancestor
Sumiyoshi feels that the fact that yo
Deecee thinks this way is tragic and he
feels very bad for the breath of the Sun
user during this scene it is suggested
that the breath of the Sun user saved
tantaros ancestor and his family at some
point in the past and it is also stated
that the breath of the Sun user does not
have a direct successor this seems to
suggest that the komiteh family is not
directly related by blood to the breath
of the Sun user but it is very possible
that since he had no successor the
breath of the Sun user decided to pass
on the breath of the Sun technique to
the Commodore family in the form of the
breath of the fire god but why is this
breath of the Sun technique so important
in the first place what's the big deal
well aside from apparently being the
first and strongest breath style out of
them all there's also the fact that
during the lifetime of your ichi Sugi
Kuni who is still the only known breath
of the sun user and the same man who had
been
with Tangier OHS ancestor at his home
the progenitor of the demons Mouzon was
nearly killed by this same breath of the
Sun user we haven't been shown the
actual battle between them at least not
yet but we know that moves on barely
managed to escape with his life and the
experience of almost being killed after
spending most of his life thinking that
he is immortal had a traumatic effect on
Musa so much so that since encountering
the breath of the Sun user Musab
continues to hide his presence from
demon Slayers by shape-shifting into
various different people and pretending
to live life as a normal human Mouzon
sphere of the breath of the Sun user is
so strong that the demons with whom
Mouzon has shared his blood can actually
feel Moo's ons fear of the breath of the
Sun user through Moo's on cells inside
their own body ever since he learned
that the komiteh family is somehow
connected to the breath of the Sun
Mouzon has been actively trying to have
tangelo killed
Muhsin considers the breath of the sun
to be perhaps the only real threat to
him and he is determined to eliminate
anyone who might be predisposed to
inheriting the breath of the sun's
powers hence with his hanafuda earrings
and the red birthmark on his face tan
Jiro quickly made his way to the top of
Mouzon skill list and of course that is
because the breath of the Sun user also
had the same hanafuda earrings and
because he also had the same red
birthmark on his face but that's not
everything that we know about the breath
of the Sun in chapter 174 of the manga
we learned that upper Moon one kakushi
bow the strongest of moves ons demon
moons and the user of the mysterious
breath of the moon is actually the older
twin brother of your reach Itsuki Cooney
the breath of the Sun user in order to
become immortal and in order to become
stronger 400 years ago kakushi bo
decided to become a demon but his
brother yuri Chi remained human
eventually this set up an epic clash
between the two brothers
and despite Goku shippo's demon powers
he was about to lose the fight against
his human brother however by the time of
that fight your Ichi was already in his
80s and he ended up dying of old age
just before he could finish koku Shiba
off this turn of events the fact that
even as
demon he would have lost to his elderly
human brother if fate hadn't interfered
maid cuckoo she bow deeply miserable for
the rest of his life the manga also
reveals that the mist pillar mu Ichiro
and his family are the direct
descendants of Kaku Sheba
back when he was still a human Kaku
Shippo had a child and mu Ichiro is a
direct descendant of this child
meaning that mu Ichiro and Kikuchi both
shared the same blood this also means
that technically mu Ichiro and the
breath of the Sun user you reach he also
shared the same blood we do not yet know
whether Kaku Shabazz breath of the Moon
style is the specific style that he
developed back when he was human and
then simply kept the same style when he
became a demon or whether as a human
cuckoo Shiba was also a breath of the
Sun user like his twin brother but when
he transformed into a demon his breath
of the Sun style also transformed into
the breath of the sun's dark counterpart
the breath of the Moon another important
aspect of the breath of the Sun that we
need to talk about is the so called mark
of the sun's state once a Demon Slayer
like tan Jiro learns to access this
state it allows him to become even
stronger and faster than usual although
being in this state is able to increased
Andros abilities he is only rarely able
to enter this state and he is only able
to use it for a small amount of time
before it takes a severe toll on his
body we were initially led to believe
that when any demon slayer manifests the
mark of the Sun on their bodies they
will become a lot more powerful but they
will also be doomed to die before they
reach the age of 25 a lot of fans were
worried that tan judo and many of their
favorite Demon Slayer characters would
be condemned to death only a few years
after manifesting their marks
however in Chapter 174 of the manga it
is revealed that your each eat Sookie
Cooney was able to live past the age of
80
despite manifesting the mark in his
youth this greatly surprised his brother
the demon kakushi ball because Kaku
Shiva had always thought that unless he
became a demon he would be dead by the
age of 25 at this time we don't know how
your Ichi managed to live past 80 with
the mark but the fact that he did gives
us hope that tun 0 and everyone else who
has manifested the mark of the Sun will
be able to find a way to live longer
than the age of 25
it is clear that the breath of the Sun
has been a huge mystery throughout the
demon slayer story and we have been
learning bits and pieces about its
history and true nature as the series
has progressed it seems pretty obvious
that the breath of the Sun will be
instrumental in one day defeating Mouzon
but the only question is who will master
it first and who will ultimately be the
one to end
Mulan's reign of terror after over 1,000
years most people believe that the one
to defeat Mouzon using the breath of the
Sun will be Tangier oh and that is
definitely a good guess based on
everything that we've seen so far
and on the fact that he is the main
protagonist but I have a slightly
different perspective I believe that the
former breath of the Sun user Yuri cheat
Sookie Cooney failed to kill Mouzon
because he tried to defeat him all on
his own we know that your each she
fought alone and he mentioned in his
conversation with chondros ancestor that
he did not have any successors it is
safe to assume that your each he was a
lone wolf who preferred to take all the
responsibility onto his own shoulders he
was an incredible warrior a legendary
warrior but in the end he simply could
not put a stop to moves on all on his
own I mentioned this in my previous
videos on Nezzer point and zero but I
find it very interesting that unlike the
breath of the Sun user pan Jiro does not
have a red sword I mean he has the
hanafuda earrings he has the mark of the
Sun he has the dance of the fire-god but
he does not have the red sword instead
he normally has a black sword but when
tundra sword comes into contact with
nazca's blood that is when tonzura sword
turns red just like the sword of the
breadth of the Sun user your Ichi I
think that this is symbolic of the wider
message of demon slayer even the
greatest warrior in history cannot
defeat the immortal evil that has moves
on on his own Mouzon can only be
defeated through teamwork and that will
mean that tangier Onizuka zenit su
inosuke and the pillars are all working
together to destroy Mouzon once and for
all on his own
tandro has a lot of the same positive
characteristics as the breath of the Sun
user your Ichi but that is not enough
only with the help of Nesbo's blood
demon art and with the help of other
demon Slayers can pan Jiro hope to one
day reach the heights of
the breath of the Sun user and perhaps
even surpass him in order to finally
destroy Mouzon but that is just my own
opinion let me know what you guys think
what new secrets about the breath of the
Sun are we going to learn next and why
is the breath of the Sun seemingly the
only breath style that can truly
threaten Mouzon is it related to the
fact that muezzins one true weakness is
sunlight itself also do you think that
kakushi bose breath of the moon is its
own unique breath style or did he also
use the breath of the Sun back when he
was still a human but it morphed into
something else once he became a demon
give me your thoughts down in the
comments I always love hearing from you
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more Demon Slayer content please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't turn on all
notifications you will definitely miss a
lot of our videos that's just how
YouTube works feel free to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest demon slayer news and
updates i want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thanks to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress on hell crews stealers
poet Pablo atropos Wraith and fitty
dalla beat and also an epic thank you to
all of ours the one tier patrons the
ones who stand up up all other clans
including Ingrid ah a Lola madam madam
AK and makoto-kun if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron only discord
and to show our gratitude your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us face cowboys
[Music]